[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the dream phone 2019. so this
is something i thought a lot about there
is no perfect phone there never has been
and even with tech getting better and
better and amazing phones out now kind
of feels like there never will be but
it's always been sort of fun to
speculate what if you could frankenstein
together the best possible version of a
phone with all the available parts in
bleeding edge tech what would that look
like last time i made a video about my
dream phone was 2014 so five years ago
baby marquez speculating about the best
tech available and what the most amazing
phone would look like and it looked like
this you know i was asking for a
snapdragon 805 three gigabytes of ram
128 gigs of storage and a 3500 milliamp
hour battery in my dream phone so
clearly times have changed i don't know
about you know the doubling of every two
years as moore's law suggests but things
have clearly taken major strides since
those lofty goals so
this is my new look at a concept for a
dream phone 2019 plus some renders to go
with it now in all honesty i'm not too
picky like i already really like some of
the phones we already have that i've
talked about during the year um i've
already tweeted like my simplified
version of the dream phone would be
something like oneplus 7 pro basically
with all the specs and the 90hz display
and the os and everything with the p30
pro's battery
and the pixels camera like that would
already be amazing but this is the dream
phone so we can really dream big and we
can be more specific since we already
know the possibility of it happening is
near zero so that's exactly what i'm to
do so the specs
now specs are less important than they
used to be but for the sake of getting
them at the bleeding edge i'll start off
by taking the chip from the iphone 10s
the a12 bionic is incredible and as
great as the snapdragon 85 is obviously
the a12 bionic is the champ as far as
power so i'll take that but then i will
take the rest of the specs from the
fastest phone i've ever used which is
the oneplus 7 pro which means
12 gigs of super fast ram and the ufs
3.0 flash storage and sent this the
dream phone it'll all just magically
work together and then the amount of
storage is actually less important than
it's ever been because of all this cloud
stuff like i feel like i could actually
be fine today with 128 gig phone i
actually download fun fact my entire
spotify library offline in the highest
quality possible every time i get a new
phone just for flights and that's less
than 100 gigs so i could be fine with
128 but for the hell of it since it's
the dream phone and we got that ufs 3.0
just give me a terabyte of flash storage
so that's the internals then let's get
to the looks
the design
the hardware so i'd have a very clean
minimal aesthetic for the hardware and
the overarching theme would be as you
guessed matte black and then you know
with just a little bit of red accents
and some carbon fiber so up front i
would take the display from the oneplus
7 pro but modify it a little bit taking
it to the next level like that's clearly
already a great panel but give me 120
hertz oled this time still 1440p and
also give me the brightness of samsung's
panels
and make it a little bit smaller so i
love the oneplus 7 pros full screen
already of course but if i had my way it
would be that little bit brighter
outdoors like the samsung screens it
would have a little bit less rounded
corners as well and it would be a little
bit smaller so i'd say a six inch 1440p
120 hertz oled now a display like that
needs a battery champion as we know so
this is a phone that's fully allowed to
be a couple extra millimeters thicker
all the better to get rid of a camera
bump i'm cool with this phone having a
little bit extra space to fit the dream
4500 milliamp hour battery so give me
the give me the battery from the red
hydrogen but also with the warp charging
of the oneplus 7 pro that would be crazy
and you can see in this design it's all
matte black with a slot of carbon fiber
down the side just for kicks give me a
colored power button of course in red
thin bezels as you can see oh and yes
i'm i'm keeping front-facing speakers
and then also since i think glass backs
are kind of a bit overrated and since
i've also been really impressed recently
with plastics the the matte black on
this phone can be polycarbonate so when
you drop it won't shatter it's all matte
black and it can also now enable
wireless charging now i could go for the
fully all screen bezel-less dream phone
that the world seems to be moving
towards but i don't think that's my
dream phone right now specifically
because i still like a good pair of
front-facing speakers and the
piezoelectric front-facing behind the
glass speakers they're okay for an
earpiece but they're just not cutting it
for the big sound that i want so my
dream phone would still have a little
top slot little bottom slot front-facing
stereo speakers and also yes i'd keep
that headphone jack because yes while i
have moved on to not really needing it
anymore
every once in a while it's convenient
just to have one so throw a quality dac
behind that and of course usb type c and
then also that speaker slot up top gives
me room for real front facing cameras so
no no notch needed no hole punch no
crazy mechanisms no pop-ups that don't
make it water resistant this can be a
water-resistant phone with real
front-facing cameras and i have two of
them i would take both the front-facing
cameras from the pixel 3 the normal and
the wide-angle they're incredible
quality of course and i love having
quality front-facing cameras so there's
your speakers and your cameras and
speaking of cameras you may have noticed
the dual rear-facing cameras on the back
of the phone and i've spoken on this
before but i would take the pixel 3's
photo quality from the cameras and the
iphone's video quality it's the best of
both worlds pixel 3 does an incredible
job with just a single lens for images
but i would actually love to see a
second lens with the same quality
hardware for amazing wide-angle shots
and since again it's my impossible dream
phone both of these are optically
stabilized and they can both do iphone
quality video and then to top it all off
my one bleeding edge wish is an under
display fingerprint reader that is the
entire bottom half of the display so no
more like fidgety having to get it just
right and lifting up your finger too
fast you just put your finger anywhere
on the bottom half and it unlocks
super fast and then toss in oxygen os or
stock android honestly either way would
be fine with me i think there's a couple
pixel specific features that i'd want
like the now playing song id that's
pretty sweet and call screening so it
would definitely have those things and
just for kicks i message for android
because why not but generally i've been
really happy with the high refresh rate
clean android experience then wrap it
all up in a nice low pocophone type of
price
and i uh i think that's my frankenstein
of a dream phone for 2019.
am i missing anything again i know a
phone like this doesn't exist couldn't
exist but i also know that you know
making my voice heard about a dream like
this can possibly push the dream just a
little bit closer to reality so there
you have it also this video was a collab
with concept creator super skilled with
the sick renders to help visualize the
phone that we were talking about in this
video so go subscribe to his channel if
you want to see more stuff like that
but that's been it that's my dream phone
what would your dream phone be let me
know in the comments below
either way
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace